en el vídeo anterior vimos los protones
en el benceno y dijimos que todos los 6
protones están en el mismo ambiente
debido a eso todos los protones son
químicamente equivalentes y deberían
darnos solo una señal en el espectro de
rm n esta es la señal en el espectro
debido a los protones del benceno si
comparamos el benceno con este compuesto
éste es tetra metil silano o tms y los
protones en el tms están todos en el
mismo ambiente por lo que esperaremos
una señal para el tms
esta es la señal para tms en un vídeo
anterior
dijimos que mientras vamos a la derecha
en el espectro de rm n encuentras
señales de fred quien sea
más
va a una señal de menor frecuencia
mientras nos movemos a la derecha en el
espectro de rm n si nos movemos a la
izquierda en el espectro de rm n estamos
hablando de una señal de frecuencia más
elevada una señal de
way sea más
tal
y entonces los protones en el benceno
tienen una señal de frecuencia más alta
que los protones en el tms el tms es de
hecho nuestro estándar porque los
protones en el tms están de hecho más
blindados que casi todos los compuestos
orgánicos por lo que es una referencia y
entonces en lugar de hablar de
frecuencia podríamos hablar de valores
de desplazamiento químico aquí y el
desplazamiento químico será una idea
similar a la frecuencia mientras vas a
la derecha estás hablando de un
desplazamiento químico más
da juego
un desplazamiento químico menor mientras
te mueves a la izquierda en el espectro
de rm me estás hablando de un
desplazamiento químico más
alto
es un desplazamiento químico mayor
cuando te mueves a la izquierda los
protones en el benceno tienen un
desplazamiento químico mayor que los
protones en cms
de hecho dejamos este igual a cero este
es nuestro estándar como descubrimos
cuál es el desplazamiento químico por
ejemplo para los protones del benceno
parece que parece que la señal aparece
un poco después de 7 aquí como obtenemos
este número para un desplazamiento
químico nuevamente todo se compara con
tms así que veamos veamos la fórmula
para calcular el desplazamiento químico
si continúa aquí abajo podemos ver la
fórmula para el desplazamiento químico
el desplazamiento químico es igual al
desplazamiento observado del tms en
hertz por 10
6 dividido entre la frecuencia del
espectrómetro en hertz por ejemplo
digamos que estamos usando el
espectrómetro de rm n con una frecuencia
de muestreo de 300 megahertz estoy
usando un espectrómetro a 300 mega hertz
aquí y para utilizar un espectrómetro de
300 megahertz los protones en el benceno
absorben una frecuencia de 2.181 hertz
más que los protones en el tms y
nuevamente el tms es nuestro estándar
nuestra referencia así que esta
diferencia si pensamos en frecuencia
esta diferencia entre estas dos señales
es 2.181
si estamos usando si estamos usando un
espectrómetro de 300 megawatts así que
continuemos y descubramos el
desplazamiento químico para los protones
del benceno hagamos un poco de espacio
aquí abajo y entonces aquí está el
símbolo para el desplazamiento químico
el desplazamiento químico es igual al
desplazamiento observado del tms que fue
de 2.181 es 2.181 hertz y necesitamos
multiplicar eso por 10 a la 6 y la razón
por la cual multiplicamos eso por 10 a
las 6 es porque el espectrómetro está en
megahertz aquí los 300 megahertz son
cientos por diez a las seis
y entonces podemos cancelar podemos
cancelar los hertz podemos cancelar 10 a
las 6 y entonces tenemos un cálculo
simple aquí para averiguar el
desplazamiento químico y entonces
continuemos haciendo eso
prendo mi calculadora 2 181 dividido
entre 300 nos da 7.27 esto es igual a
7.27 mira como los gers se cancelaron y
tenemos aquí de tm o partes por millón
porque las señales son reportadas como
una fracción de la frecuencia de
muestreo del espectrómetro y hay una
razón por la cual hacemos eso obtenemos
este número 7.27 aquí hagamos este
cálculo otra vez
digamos que hicimos esto corrimos el
espectro en un espectrómetro distinto
digamos que usamos un espectrómetro de
60 megahertz cambiémoslo un poco
un espectrómetro de 60 mega hertz
si uso un espectrómetro de 60 megahertz
los protones en el benceno van a
absorber una frecuencia de 436 shirts
más que los protones en el tms
así que si calculamos el desplazamiento
químico ahora la diferencia sería 436
hertz por 10 a las 6 y / ahora estamos
usando un espectrómetro de 60 megahertz
por 60 por 10 a la 6 hertz nuevamente
los karts se cancelan los 10 a las 6 se
cancelan y podemos hacer esos cálculos
tenemos 4 3-6 dividimos eso entre 60 y
obtenemos 7.27 otra vez obtenemos 7.27
observa que obtuvimos el mismo valor que
aquí arriba 7.27 es una constante no
importando qué tipo de espectrómetro
usemos podríamos usar un espectrómetro
de 300 megahertz o uno de 60 megahertz
obtendrás el mismo valor para el
desplazamiento químico es por eso que
vamos a través de estos cálculos de aquí
obtenemos un valor constante para los
desplazamientos químicos los protones en
el benceno tienen un desplazamiento
químico de 7.27 y hablaremos más de
desplazamientos químicos en los
siguientes vídeos